hey guys I'm Lucien welcome to in two
minutes apologies for the absence for
the last couple of weeks you know that
big III thing happened you know square
finally announced that they were
remaking final fantasy 7 Shenmue 3 got a
kick starter the last Guardians not dead
Nintendo are finally making Metroid 3ds
I don't know anyway I digress this
week's episode is all about the biggest
gaming betrayals but given that this
year's e3 was pretty much fan fiction
it's kind of irrelevant because nobody
really got portrayed at all well apart
from that one time Brian what are you
waiting for do it clock's ticking let's
go
in the dilapidated aperture laboratory
that's full of machines that are trying
to kill you it should have come as no
surprise when your chirpy AI companion
Wheatley also tries to kill you he
starts out as your pal but after being
plugged into the mainframe of GLaDOS he
gets slightly corrupted so instead of
your dear intelligence dampening sphere
helping you to escape the facility he
goes mad with power and tries to rebuild
the facility in his own image which is
troubling because he's an idiot he also
ends up putting GLaDOS consciousness
into a potato which is both equal parts
nefarious and genius now there are
twists and turns beyond count in Metal
Gear but when it comes to back stabs no
one plunges a knife deeper than McDonald
Miller your former mentor appears as you
crawl your way through the icy cold
vents of Shadow Moses offering to help
you survive the harsh Alaskan climate of
course you're gonna trust him and when
you inadvertently activate metal gears
doomsday countdown probably one of
snakes lowest moments as a stealth
operative trying to save the world from
nuclear catastrophe you discover that
that's not master Miller at all turns
out Miller was dead the whole time and
the guy stringing you along was your
evil twin brother liquid snake and you
had no idea it's unbelievable what
putting on some large shades can do then
this pigma from starfox a member of the
original elite starfox team he betrays
his comrades and murders Fox McLeod's
father James under the orders of body
and Ross he gets kicked out of both the
good guys and the bad guys for being too
evil and he's basically a massive joke
daddy
hood before he died now when you arrive
in a mysterious spooky place and you're
being attacked by weird drug-addled
clambering guys and a friendly Irish
voiceover a radio offers you help in
exchange for completing a few simple
tasks well you've really got no choice
but to follow them it happens in
BioShock with a guy named atlas he's
just a regular Joe caught up in the
uprising he helped by warning you about
impending danger and he has a great
accent why wouldn't you trust him well
it turns out that he's been manipulating
you the whole time with a catchphrase
and basically makes you his own personal
hitman worst of all that Irish accent
was fake I know I couldn't believe it
either anyway which gaming betrayals cut
you to the core and after you unable to
trust again let me know in the comments
section below I'll be back again next
week but in the meantime I'll be on
twitter at Lucy James games I'll see you
next time
you